you know the other thing we ask people
to do and I'm talking about this because
it's very practical you might say well I
don't know what I want it's like okay
well what other people have that it
seems to work for them you probably want
a relationship what's your vision for
that you probably want to have something
approximating a family of some sort
what's your vision for that even if it's
your parents not children necessary not
even a wife necessarily some family
connections some friendship some job or
career some educational goals some
strategy for dealing with Temptations
that's five things some conception of
how you would use your time
intelligently outside of work
um some conception of how you might what
would you say uphold your civic
responsibility yeah there's there's
sources of meaning that people that
people generally have